I'm very excited to see Paul Bettany
made the jump from my voice to fool of
an on-screen yeah yeah no Malcolm work
for my money I used to turn up to a dark
room for 45 minutes and get back cash
and now i have to work so that it has x
rays meant for you everybody's been
incredibly welcoming and spinning yards
the month it's exciting for me it's been
the most exciting thing that's ever
happened to my children did you call dad
points for this simply have no
interested what I did until this month
and now all the neighborhood kids are
gonna be turning up your house and
asking you to the boys now you know how
to keep this secret for a year and a
half and so my kids which is pretty
impressive you know it's cool that I
just didn't bring what then you know if
I welcomed Jade sweeter is it even a
comic had before is this your first
never good I came last year to comic-con
for a TV show I do called the blacklist
and you know I just want to say
something to all of you guys is I am
I've always thought my whole life that
life could never get weird or crazy
enough for me
tell you something this place may be the
weirdest gyarados it's cuz of all of you
guys and so I thank you for that because
it is really fantastically crazy here
you should tell yourselves on the back
everyone that you are now a part of
James faders weird fever dreams the one
what can you tell you when you say about
Ultron and my kids and your approach to
to the role and kind of what you want to
bring to it I plan eight-foot robot in
this movie and it was it was I've always
played humans it was shooting this film
as startling and surprising and
challenging and exciting as coming here
truthfully for the first time it was
doing this film was everything
everything was so entirely new the
process of making it playing this
character all of the people the world
that I was entering even the world that
these movies inhabit not just in terms
of story in place and people and so on
but also just the part of the movie
business it was just imagining
unimaginably exciting I'm just gonna
magically excitement also welcome
Elizabeth
it's like quite a list of people to
follow right now it is your last one
doesn't feel that great no it's good hey
and so you're the other you're the other
new character on the block so speak
terms of Scarlet Witch and so what is
your experience tonight coming into the
group and being another new nail it's
been awesome I was first really
intimidated by all of the people i was
going to potentially work with and then
everyone was incredibly welcoming and
it's just been so much fun and it's fun
to bring a new element to the game
there's now magic there's you know you
too mutated people get then went on to
add for you mutants bad word yeah yeah I
think it ends up and like adding
something kind of epic to the vice that
there's just a new element it's just not
just you know awesome punching and I
don't know like now we gotta do
something different and I think it it
brings up with but we're Marvel's going
with their other phones as well and
having all the it's just like the
beginning kind of feels like just the
beginning when you're preparing a
character that does all the things that
she does any differently preparing just
mr. just playing a regular non which yes
i crack this daily just like staring at
a pencil
it's not where I them it's what is it
working at this your shared galing it
she actually cast a spell on me two
weeks ago and I'm just hopefully before
this is all done she'll Ruby be in it it
burns
you guys we can't be getting giddy dish
early no obviously you probably notice
that Scarlett Johansson was not able to
be here even though I know that that she
wanted to be here Scarlett wanted to be
here Scarlett is pregnant and and since
a little message if you want to see ya
to cramp her style dance with running
out of time here hey Kathy want to be
exalted was that the hitch that's right
she gets right to the point ah Joss I
couldn't be here in person ja said
something so he's definitely here in
spirit the first look Avengers age of
Ultron
I know I know I'm not supposed to swear
but holy that's insane I didn't
know I mean okay you saw that and you
saw Ultron I don't know how you top
Ultron bad guy wise you know the great
thing about Marvel is they've always got
the next thing up their sleeve so uh
well you know we got Thanos
where's my rose
so much we're so excited thanks for
coming Ricky try to do our best for you
Cass
I don't know where you go from here it
doesn't get better than this but I hope
you guys have a nice safe